hätten sie gedacht dass dieser film auf
einem handy gedreht wurde
denn green sorgte am diesjährigen
sundance film festival für aufsehen als
die macher nach der premiere offenlegten
alles auf dem smartphone gedreht was
hollywood kann können wir auch
dieser beitrag wird also auf einem
smartphone gedreht vom potenzial der do
it yourself filmchen ist auch andrea
holle überzeugt darum hat sie das erste
internationale handy filmfestival momo
in der schweiz ausgerufen
die stil ist einfach sich möglichst
viele filme machen auf der ganzen welt
die möglichkeit geändert plattform
größeren mitmachen und das bios
möglichst viel geschichte zusammenfindet
und vielleicht ergibt sich ein anderer
film dann ist größtes projekt das geld
sammelte andrea holle via crowdfunding
dabei überzeugte sie die
textildesignerin celia an tunnels einen
handy film zu drehen
als der schnee kam kam auch die
inspiration zwischen der nacht auf
neujahr und da seid so viel schneit das
bis zu den hüften und das ist ganz
lustig sie und der kamera bei der
lustige szene dreht damit schnell und ja
hier was ist ihr erster smartphone 3
mit einem simplen programm brachte sich
celia antun es selbst das schneiden bei
wenn teures equipment fehlt heißt die
losung hilf dir selbst so eine art mini
drohne einfach hoch in die luft und im
papier also wenn der flieger fliegt das
mit der drohne das verfolgen
not macht erfinderisch eine
flugsimulation kriegt man auch anders
hin
filme über 200 filme aus der ganzen welt
sind für den internationalen wettbewerb
eingereicht worden
ist das jetzt die demokratisierung der
filmbranche
es geht in richtung demokratisierung
also türen er werde das machen im film
drei alles was man braucht ist ein
smartphone
und natürlich ebenfalls nominiert für
den mord philipp antoni ein filmprofi
mitinhaber einer kleinen filmproduktion
in bern mit seinem handy film
nachtschicht tummelt er sich im horror
genre
dem profi stellen sich andere
herausforderungen als dem laien
hauptschwierigkeiten smartphones 3
gesagt dass man jede
steuerungsmöglichkeit recht limitiert
ist das ist natürlich ein vorteil oder
verlegt wo nicht professionell machen
weil ich klassisch aus automatisiert es
funktioniert wo aus aber natürlich mache
um es gewohnt dass man die vollkasko
punktgenau sei ein verstoß von apple
iphone auch kurzweilig kräuter am anfang
war das nackte smartphone die
fortgeschrittenen aber haben längst
aufgerüstet aus dem handlichen ding wird
hoppla hopp eine stattliche kamera mit
allerlei zubehör
schon was anderes als bei unserem
kameramann philipp antoni ist bereits an
seinem nächsten film eine poetische
kindergeschichte werbegeschäft worte zu
machen
also es gibt sehr gute geschäfte
ausgezeichnet
goldige zeiten für unentdeckte talente
mit schmalem budget aber großen story
ideen nur angucken
das macht immer noch am meisten spaß auf
der professionellen großleinwand